[wind blowing]
[footsteps]
[ominous music]
♪
- THERE'S GOTTA BE ANOTHER
HUMAN BEING OUT THERE.
SOMEWHERE.
IT'S BEEN 173 DAYS
SINCE THE UNDOING.
TODAY, I MAY BE
THE LAST MAN ALIVE.
HOWEVER, IF THERE IS ANOTHER,
I WILL FIND THEM.
THE LONELINESS
IS MORE THAN I CAN--
[scooter engine revs]
- WHOO-HOO!
YEAH! WHEE!
HA HA!
WHOO-HOO. YO.
[engine shuts off]
AHH.
LET ME GET SOME OF THAT.
MM. MMM.
MM-HMM, MM-HMM, MM-HMM.
[dance music]
OH, YEAH!
[muffled]
THAT'S MY JAM RIGHT THERE!
WHOO!
HAZZAH!
WAH, SHAKIKAH!
WAH, SHASLIKAH!
OOH, Y'ALL DON'T KNOW
NOTHIN' ABOUT THAT.
MM, MM.
PTT-PTT-PTT-PTT.
OH, HEY BABY,
HOW YOU DOING?
[grunts]
YEAH!
WHAT,
ALL DAY, BABY!
[grunts]
YEAH!
[thuds]
WHOA, HEY!
DUDE!
UM, HEY, I'LL--
I'LL COME OVER THERE.
DUDE! HEY!
I'LL COME TO YOU, MAN.
[gunshot]
[gun clicks]
[music ends]
- OKAY, THERE HAS TO BE ANOTHER
HUMAN BEING OUT THERE...
SOMEWHERE.